foreign
in Atlanta Georgia what's up brother Jim
hi Dr John how are you I'm good man how
are you I'm doing great thanks for
taking my call you got what's up oh you
got hold on you got it dude I don't even
know I was feeling great today I got all
my breathing exercise like I'm feeling
great I guess my words aren't working or
am I singing or my memory I feel that
other than those three things I'm all
cylinders so what's up man
um so uh I've got a really good friend
whom I've known for 13 years now and
we've served in Ministry together I'm
still in Ministry uh he works at a
daycare now and um there's some
indication that he might have a
pedophilic attractions
um and I just don't know how to handle
that as his friend
hmm
so I'll start first by saying thank you
for this call I appreciate that and
recognizing that something needs to
happen you don't know what to do yeah
and I'll follow it up with
what are you doing man
um like what's the what's the hold up
like what's the I don't know like where
are you getting stuck
it's the way I see it is that there's a
lot of yellow flags but I haven't seen
like a red flag yet
um and believe me if I knew that there
was
like a Surefire like something had
happened after all the cops right of
course there's no doubt about it all
right good good so what makes you think
give me some examples of
as he told you this stuff have you seen
him looking at things on the internet
that he showed I mean like how do you
how what's causing you to think he might
have some Tendencies along these lines
sure
um about three years ago we were having
a really kind of vulnerable conversation
about
about stuff and struggle and everything
um and he mentioned that he had
previously dealt with a pornography
problem which is awful but it's not
exactly rare right it's something that a
lot of us have gone through but it's the
opposite of of rear yes right yeah yeah
very common
um but uh when I when he started sharing
some details he said that
um the subject matter was beginning to
scare him and he used the words younger
and younger to describe what was
happening okay
um now that's not exactly uh you know
confession but it was some it was a
that's a yellow flag for me and then
ever since then I've been noticing some
things that with that filter just don't
sit right with me and give me an example
uh some of them so he he works at this
daycare
um he becomes really fixated on specific
kids in his class it seems
um so much so that he will break the
rules and he'll take pictures
appropriate pictures but he'll take
pictures of them and save them oh hell
no dude Jim
we don't have any these aren't yellow
flags
okay okay now a buddy confessing to you
three or four years ago that man I like
looking at naked people and the naked
people I like looking at are getting
I'm I'm trending towards a younger thing
that's a vulnerable moment that somebody
being honest with you that in and of
itself doesn't indicate anything right
but as you said now you've got that lens
on you're wearing a pair of glasses that
he handed you right and now you are
going to rightfully so view things uh
view his actions through that lens so
let's have another one let's say he
leans over to you one day and y'all are
having vulnerable bro time deal drink
ipas it just feels like an IPA
conversation
no he does I do once in a while but I'm
I'm more of a mixed drink kind of all
right thank you thank you be a grown-up
all right so
um
so
let's say he's y'all are having one of
your
IPA mixed drink in the evenings and he
says hey I really have this weird thing
for wanting to hook up with other
people's wives and you were like oh
that's strange explore and he's like
well it's kind of a power thing like I
want to be I want them to you know I
mean like he just goes down this weird
fantasy he's got I even call it weird I
just he's got a fantasy I'm not even
gonna judge you it just is what it is
then you show up next week and he's
sitting by your wife with his arm around
her and they're just laughing
uh you would immediately go hey homie
back that thing up you know what I mean
and not in that way that song was
originally written right you would tell
him hey like you and me are going to
parking lot right or you're not gonna
fight him but you'd get right in the
middle of that yeah and so you don't
want your friend to be a pedophile
no your friend is taking pictures of
children that he works with after
telling you I'm really
I'm really finding myself increasingly
turned on by kids and I can think of
no greater
um
I have deep compassion for somebody that
finds himself in a situation where they
find children attractive in a sexualized
way and my heart breaks for them what a
tortured life right because there's so
much joy with kids so much Wonder so
much love I I do have compassion for
them
and I'll be damned if they're gonna ever
ever
heard a kid on my watch absolutely right
and so you've got other examples what's
another example here
that makes you uncomfortable
yeah so
um he
he and I are in kind of like a friend
Circle and his uh his siblings are a
part of that as well
um and they have kids
sometimes just the way that he interacts
with their uh one of their daughters
just makes me feel just uneasy
um certain kind of lap settings and hugs
and kisses type thing that and I I'm
having a hard time Discerning whether or
not like am I feeling weird about this
because of that filter is this actually
pretty normal and there's all of that
stuff that I'm just like I don't know
and then there's uh
um he part of the story is that he
confessed to someone else some of this
is all kind of vague
and then he said that he underwent some
counseling for it but I think that ended
up just being like a guy at church
um
yeah and that's and so my question
though is like I think it's falling upon
me to have this conversation with him
and I just don't know how to even
approach it all right so
um my there's a great um I saw it on the
on the interwebs it was it really
brought joy to my heart
um I think we talked about on the show
Kelly I think you don't want to send it
to me but it was a dad posted he was
walking out of a store and he was
holding his daughter and like I don't
remember it was like TJ Maxx or
something and she wanted to grab some of
the stuff that he had to keep your hands
off of it she throws a fit so he's
carrying her out of the store buy one
leg or something over his shoulder and
she's just having a a walleye temper
tantrum and he's getting her out of the
store and she's screaming and a man is
walking into the store and stops him in
the parking lot
and says honey are you okay and she says
no I'm not okay am I this man or my
daddy's hurting me or whatever and
finally the dad explains it the dad went
on to post on the internets
thank you to this man for seeing
something that he thought didn't sit
right with him and calling it out I'd
rather err on the side of hey young lady
is this man hurting you then
not say anything see something weird
right so
anytime it comes to kids this is my
personal rules my wife's personal
anytime I'm I see something unsavory
with kids I'm gonna err on the side of
saying something every time 100 time and
if you're the kind of person that me
that you see me asking you a hard
question or feel me or hear me asking
you a hard question about your
relationship with a child or children
and you don't that doesn't raise my your
respect for me but in fact you're like
how dare you who do you eat bro then
dude I want nothing to do I don't have
time for you in my life
right yeah so that's the that's the lens
with which I look in the world okay
that's the way how it's uh how I operate
now I'm not better than anybody else I'm
not like trying to line I I just have a
thing about people hurting kids
you know I mean so
I would be call your friend and you all
set up a time just you two no
embarrassment know anything
and
I would be very very direct
and I would also put a cap on it and so
here's what I mean by that a few years
ago brother you told me you were
struggling with X Y and Z it's also I've
heard through somebody that you can find
in somebody else you got counseling for
this stuff fine
I'm super uncomfortable with the way you
interact with your nieces and nephews
especially your nieces the way they sit
on your lap the way there's something
that feels sexualized about that dude
what are you talking about I would never
stop I'm talking and you can respond
when I'm done
when I found out you were taking photos
of kids in your daycare center that's
enough it's over yeah you're gonna
resign from this position here
and you and I are gonna go sit you're
gonna fess up and let me know where you
are
and if there you know what I think you
let them know I am going to have to
contact the authorities on this I I I'm
willing to lose the friendship over
protecting these kids but I don't feel
like they're safe
yeah and I think you I my my initial
thought is since you're not looking at a
Smoking Gun here is to say you resigned
from this job today
but my fear is he goes all right you're
right and then he's confirmed it and
then you need to get the police involved
right right yeah
um or he's like no way dude what are you
talking about and you're in the same
boat I think you let him know hey this
is coming
um I have reported this and you're gonna
have to resign and if I'm wrong I'm
sorry
but what I'm seeing with these kids I
just can't accept
yeah okay
and man he goes through an investigation
he's found there's nothing on his
computers there's nothing on his phones
there's nothing at home nothing like
that
um then he's Vindicated you're
Vindicated and I think you'd be honest
with him and say I understand that you
might feel like this is a violation of
our friendship you might feel like XYZ
but I'm protecting these kids and I'm
protecting you and here's the thing this
is you handling a problem that you
didn't start and so I don't want you to
feel like
um
not if but when this thing goes sideways
which it will you know and if you have a
friend grouped and his brothers and
sisters are going to be like I can't
believe you accused him all that stuff
and let's be honest if it's true they
know
right they know they've been
uncomfortable or seen some things or you
know what I mean
um
but it's just not worth the risk for
those kids and you had dude The Smoking
Gun for me is taking pictures of kids at
a daycare
yeah I worked with I was an elementary
school teacher for you it never even
crossed my mind to take a photo right
you know what I mean yeah I worked with
high school kids and they would give me
a picture like their they're like
they're you know they're they get a
packet of photos you know their yearbook
pictures they'd bring those to me and I
was uncomfortable that yeah see what I
mean those are high school kids they
were great I mean they're and I was like
ah you know what I mean and so
anybody taking photos of children uh
come on man I mean you know what I mean
hey absolutely can you be honest with me
for one second
sure there's a big one you haven't told
me what's the big one
well
um I think
so I have actually brought this up with
his siblings yep and they kind of
confirmed that they had the same
thoughts without a Smoking Gun as well
um okay dude all of y'all are smelling
smoke the house is on fire
that's a good way it's like everybody
smell like I just can't see the Flames I
guess we're cool let's just keep
watching TV do the house on fire
everybody smells it yeah
cool and maybe if you've got a great
relationship with them tell them it's
coming
sure do they know about the photos at
the daycare center and all that they
know about all of it and they have tried
to look into stuff themselves and it
seems like they'd rather not deal with
it honestly
um this is their kid I know and what it
seems like to me though is that they
because there's no slam dunk here they
feel like well we're just either being
paranoid and there's a and whatever
struggle he is going through the phrase
that they use it they found out that
there's an action plan in place
and I'm like I don't know what that
means that doesn't make me feel any
better here's the action plan I'm
calling the cops
yeah and I'd call a detective a
non-emergency detective and say I've got
some pretty clear indicators this is
happening families confirmed it
um now I've heard these taking photos of
kids or I've seen the photos of kids or
he's told me about them and
um I'm throwing red flag on this one we
need someone to go investigate this
yeah and I'd probably contact I'd
contact him and let him know he's got 10
hours to resign he needs to resign today
get out of there today quit yeah I don't
care I don't care anything he's a quit
today
um and here's the thing he may go take
his life
that's that's another thing I'm really
afraid of he might he might I need you
to hear me say that's not on you
yeah the fear no no it's easier to say
right it's easy to make just throw that
out there you're like okay cool well
cool right I know it's harder than that
um
but
you can't control what happens next what
you can control is right now in the now
right and that is I'm stepping up
because no other adult in this
unbelievable situation like I can feel
my blood pressure going up right now I I
even did my little fancy breathing
techniques this morning before I got on
the air and I'm still feeling I'm still
feeling them rise like somebody's got to
step in should be this kid's parents I
mean the kids the parents of you imagine
just seeing you have kids
I don't know okay I'm just I've got a
six-year-old little girl
yeah dude I'm just
if I'm just imagining her sitting on
some man's lap and getting that feeling
like nope nope you know what I mean
um yeah anyway we could talk about this
all day man I don't want to belabor the
point today today and I don't know what
you have on your docket today it's
canceled cancel it man call them and say
dude I cannot go another day with I I'm
stepping in the middle of this on behalf
of these kids and if I'm wrong so be it
I'll find some other friends to have
mixed drinks with and that's one less
IPA Drinker you have to hang out with
about that that's the Silver Lining here
Jim
um hopefully his brothers and sisters
will stand up and say thank God yeah we
didn't have the courage to do it or
what's gonna happen is they're gonna
find his laptop and everybody's gonna be
vomiting
um and rightfully so because they should
have stepped up a long time ago today's
the day my brother sorry you're in the
middle of this but I'm grateful that
you're in the middle of this because
somebody's got to do something about it
and you're the guy